ديانا
اليوم الاول للغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا لانني
كنت في مدينه ماريوبول اتذكر جيدا كانت
الساعه قد تجاوزت الخامسه بقليل قبلها
بليله كنا نعمل لوقت متاخر في المدينه
وسمعت ضوضاء في الفندق حيث كنا نحن في
البدايه كان هذا الصوت غريبا كما بدلي كما
لو ان هناك اناسا تتشاجر فيما بينها لكن
عندما فتحت عيني ونظرت الى هاتف الجوال
كان هناك سيل من الرسائل رساله واحده لن
انساها من اختي تقول الغزو قد بدا
بالتوفيق كوني حذره
[موسيقى]
انا والزميله جولي دنجل فالتقينا الذهاب
الى موسكو في بدايه هذا النزاع او هذه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وكما يسميها
الروس بالعمليه الخاصه كانت هناك فئه
كبيره من الشباب او الجيل الشباب الروسي
رافضين للحرب واقل قليله من كبار السن فقط
هم من يؤيد هذه الحرب كان انقسام في
الشارع ولا حظنا هناك قلق كبير ايضا من
قبل شارع الروسي لما يحدث من قرارات ايضا
اقتصاديه وعقوبات دوليه
عديده هي الاشكاليات التي نقع فيها
كمراسلين ميدانيين خاصه واننا لا نعرف
الكثير حول الطبيعه المكان هذه للمره
الاولى نذهب الى اماكن كهذا نكون حذرين
للغايه لانها مناطق النزاع هناك حرب هناك
قنابل هناك
جواسيس من الطرف الروسي كذلك هناك حذر
كبير جدا من طرف الجيش الاوكراني نسعى الى
جمع عدد كبير من المعلومات قبل الدخول في
مناطق النزاع او مدن خطره نوعا ما على
حياتنا كصحفيين من المدن
البدايه كانت من اكياف ايضا كنت في
ماريوبل
ومباشره بعد اندلاع هذه الحرب توجهت ايضا
الى
نيبرو الى
فينيسيا
واتذكر ايضا كان هناك هذا السؤال للخروج
من اوكرانيا بعد ما قصف مطار مدينه كيف
كان هناك خيار من اثنين اما التوجه الى
بولندا واما التوجه الى مولدوفا الى
مولدافيا
اتخذنا القرار الثاني وانا ذاك كانت
السيارات عمليا زحمه السيارات على مدى
كيلومترات الناس في حاله صدمه النساء
والاطفال مع حيواناتهم الاليفه ومع ما
امكن من امتعه كثيرون الالاف كانوا
يحاولون الخروج من اوكرانيا بالنسبه
ذهبنا في
الصيف وكان هناك قتال الشرس بين الروس
وكذلك الاوكرانيين وصلنا الى مدينه بخمود
التي هي اليوم ساحه
لعراك عنيف بين الروس والاوكرانيين قمنا
باستقاء عدد من المعلومات تحدثنا مع
العسكريين الموجودين في ساحه الحرب
بالاضافه الى السكان الذين بقيوا في
المدينه تقريبا عندما ذهبنا كان عددهم
5000 شخص في مدينه كانت كان بها اكثر من
70 الف اوكراني هناك هذه هؤلاء قرروا
البقاء في مدينتهم لانهم لا
يمكنهما الذهاب الى مدن اخرى نظرا لعدم
امتلاكهم للاموال الكافيه للسفر او لوسيله
نقل
[موسيقى]
التقينا في مقر بلديه ميكو لايف وبعد
اللقاء مباشره ايضا تم قصف هذا المبنى
ودمر بالكامل فكانت هذه اللحظات صعبه خاصه
ونحن يعني قضينا يوما كامل في الانتظار في
هذا المبنى والتقينا باشخاص يعملون في هذا
المبنى لكن العديد منهم قضى في هذه
العمليه عمليه عمليه استئذاف هذا المبنى
فاتذكر الى الان وجوه هؤلاء الاوكرانيون
الذين كانوا يعملون في هذا المبنى الكثير
من الحكايات والشخصيات تؤثر فينا في
الميدان ربما يحضر الى باليان او تحضر
بالاحلى هذه الشخصيه هي ممرضه التقيتها في
مستشفى عسكري في مكان ما قرب مخموت كانت
سيده بالغه الانا كانت حاضره على كل
الجبهات لا تتوقف عن العمل صورنا مع هذه
السيده مقابله ووضعنا حتى جزءا من
مشاركتها في العمل في التقرير لكن لاحقا
عادت الينا وقالت لحظه لحظه عائلتي لا
تعلم اني هنا رجاء عدم بث المقابله ورجاء
قوموا بتغطيه وجهي لا اريدهم ان يعلموا
انني في هذه البقعه تحديدا وبالطبع هذه
قاعده مقدسه بالنسبه الي وبالنسبه الى
زميل جيمس اندري عندما يطلب منا شخص ما
ذلك حتى لو كانت المقابله بالغه الاهميه
من حيث المعلومات وغيرها ننفذ
هولا
المراسل الصحفي او الميداني في ساحات
القتال
يعني لديه علاقات مع الناس وما بعد ذلك
يرحل عن هذا المكان تاركا وراءه عددا من
الاشخاص الذين
من خلال تناول وجبه غذاء او الحديث او شيء
من هذا القبيل ولكن المحزن انك تعود
ادراجك ولكن الاخرون ان يبقون في ساحه
الحرب وهذا امر صعب نوعا ما انسانيا